we are just over a year into the
pandemic and more than 13 percent of
people in the u.s are
fully vaccinated this morning we're
hearing from some of them about how it
is changing their lives
we spoke with karishma a behavioral
therapist
judith a retiree kareem an elementary
school principal
and evelyn a grandmother
the one word i would describe after
getting fully vaccinated
is relieved here you are judith i felt
at peace i just cried i was so grateful
rejuvenated almost like we have a second
opportunity we get to start again
after i got my final dose i was like
that's it i'm about to live my best life
i went to the 76ers game obviously this
is something that i would not have
even thought about doing a couple of
months ago i was not able to visit
my mother at the facility
just seeing her is very important to me
just to hear her little remarks
makes me so very happy something i
couldn't do because of covid
all of 2020 was going to disney world
and so now
that i'm fully vaccinated and it's 20 21
i'm going
it's happening my daughter and
granddaughter
came to my apartment because
they had a gift for me to my amazement
was a prescription from my doctor
and she wrote you are allowed to hug
your granddaughter
that hug is a hug i'm going to remember
forever
oh wow i love that all right i got a lot
of questions cbs news medical
contributor dr
david agus joins us now david good
morning my wife got her second shot over
the weekend i get mine tomorrow i got a
lot of questions too because
we all want those hugs my first is
there are still restrictions for people
who've had both
vaccination shots why are they and what
are they
well let me just explain what's going on
and so when you get the vaccine and
you're exposed to covet 19
70 of people will have nothing no virus
at all
30 can have a small level of virus and
either be asymptomatic
or a small number mildly symptomatic
what we don't know
is if those people can spread the virus
to vulnerable we don't think so
in the united kingdom in areas that are
vaccinated went down dramatically
so until we have more data and we know
from the challenge studies which are
defining what immunity is
in england right now we're saying when
you go out of the house you have to wear
masks even if you're vaccinated but in
the house
people who are vaccinated can get
together i had my first dinner party
with another couple because we were all
vaccinated it was
wild i felt like i was doing something
against the law
we heard the young woman say she wanted
to go to disney world i want to go to a
mets game
can we do those things
the mets game is you know emotionally is
going to be very difficult for you but
yes
and so if you're vaccinated and you can
make a good immune response
so that is there's a subset of people
people with leukemias lymphomas
who are on diseases that suppress the
immune system that even if they're
vaccinated i don't want them going out
to places
until they have a blood test and the
blood test is an antibody test
that shows that they're making
antibodies what we call spike protein
it's different than the classic antibody
test to say were you exposed in the past
to cope at 19
this is an anti-spike protein antibody
test and if that number is high
yes you can go out um the cdc has not
released
any travel guidance yet david but we are
seeing flight bookings
go up what is your advice at this point
about traveling
airplanes are amazingly safe they make
you wear masks
every two or three minutes with their
filters there they filter out hepa
filter fills without virus
so i do think if you do it right
traveling is totally safe if you are
vaccinated
the key thing is what happens if you
have a child and so if you have a child
and you play by the cdc rules is that
your child is with you and you're not
with
other unvaccinated people it's
absolutely fine and i think you know go
for it go for that trip that you've been
holding off
obviously it's going to be in the united
states because we're the only country
that
really is up there and vaccinating
besides israel in the uk
there's some confusion david about
whether people should get the vaccine
after actually recovering from the
coronavirus
what do you know about that
when you have the coronavirus you make
lots of immune response and
most of it is to parts of the virus that
don't provide immunity
so you still need that vaccine because a
hundred percent of the immune response
to the vaccine is to that spike protein
and it blocks the virus from guinea and
its immunity all right dr david agus i'm
looking forward to some of your wild
dinners thank you very much
that struck me too david egg is wild and
i can't imagine david agus any
circumstances
you'd be breaking the law i don't know
it sounds pretty crazy to me